en 2021 nous avons détecté pour
l'ensemble du département 786 fraudes
pour détecter ses fraudes nous avons
mené des contrôles trois types de
contrôle soit des contrôles automatisés
c'est-à-dire des échanges de données
soit des contrôles sur pièces en
sollicitant des documents auprès des
allocataires soit des contrôles sur
place en allant chez la locataire ou en
les faisant venir dans notre accueil
pour contrôler leur situation et
examiner leurs dossiers
[Musique]
alors les prestations qui sont les plus
complexes ce sont le RSA et la prime
pour l'activité parce qu'il y a beaucoup
effectivement de changements par rapport
aux situations aux ressources et c'est
là où il peut y avoir le plus d'erreurs
et parfois aussi le plus de fraudes il
faut bien différencier une erreur qui
est de bonne foi et une situation de
fraude où il y a effectivement intention
de frauder et de percevoir un du monde
des ressources
la sanction c'est principalement une
pénalité financière à rembourser en plus
de l'Indus et ça peut aller jusqu'à une
sanction pénale en déposant plainte
auprès du tribunal
soit un recouvrement amiable c'est à
dire qu'on contacte la locataire et
spontanément il nous rembourse soit un
recouvrement forcé chez nous et ensuite
chez lui huissier c'est-à-dire qu'on
transmet les dossiers à l'huissiers pour
effectivement mettre en place ce
recouvrement forcé et forcer les
allocataires à rembourser les sommes
notre objectif c'est de recouvrer 100%
des sommes pour effectivement avoir une
bonne gestion des fonds publics par
rapport à ces situations d'un dieu ou de
fraude
[Musique]